Çeviri: Orkun Nazim Kadioglu
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Hepinize merhaba!
Hayli içli, böyle dokunaklı ve biraz ürkek
içine kapanık bir kız çocuğuydum aslında.
Annem, önümüzden geçen ambulansın
ardından üç gün ağladığımı söyler durur.
Acaba içindeki hastaneye yetişti mi,
kurtuldu mu diye.
İlkokulda notlarımın 1,25 – 1,50’nin
üzerine geçtiğini pek hatırlamam ama
hani her yedi yılda bir insanın
saçının, cildinin bile
kabuk değiştirdiği söylenir ya sanıyorum
ben de tam 15 yaşımda
yatılı okul için dört yıllığına
İsviçre’ye gittiğimde
kişiliğim, karakterim tam da bu
zamanda kabuk değiştirdi.
Sonrasında üniversiteye gittim
ama annemin eteğinden
ayrılmadığım gerçeği hiçbir
zaman değişmedi bu arada.
Üniversiteye gittim, dört
yıllık üniversiteyi
üç senede alelacele takdir
teşekkürle bitirdim.
Sanki ilerisini görmüş gibi
televizyon bölümünün
yanı sıra bir de psikoloji okudum,
mezun oldum, döndüm.
Bu hiçbir zaman okul sıralarını çok
sevdiğim anlamına gelmesin,
çünkü sonrasındaki iş hayatım benim
her zaman gerçeğim ve
aslında hayat tarzım oldu.
Yine küçükken annem beni bir gün
Taksim Meydanı’na götürmüş,
el ele yolda yürüyoruz birlikte
yoldan geçen bir deli üzerime tükürmüş.
Annem tabii pimpirikli
koşa koşa eve dönmüşüz,
beş gün boyunca beni
çiteleye çiteleye yıkamış,
bu tabii ki benim 1999 yılında
-NTV’de muhabir olarak işe
başladığım yıla dek-
Taksim Meydanı’nı son kez görüşüm oldu.
Sonra 1999 yılında, NTV’de
staj dönemi başladı ilk önce.
Kapıdan içeriye girdim; hangi bölüme
girmeliyim, ne yapmalıyım diye…
Baktım işte kültür sanat bölümü,
sanatlar, sanat dersleri, sergiler var,
işte çokça konserler… Hiç bana göre değil.
Ekonomi bölümüne gittim, rakamlarla
aram hiçbir zaman çok iyi olmadı.
TEFE, TÜFE, kahvaltılı
basın toplantıları…
Orası da beni çok sarmadı.
Spor bölümüne geçtim.
İşte maçlar, skorlar…
Yok burası da değil dedim.
En son haber merkezine girdim, istihbarat
bölümünde tam da kendimi buldum.
İçimdeki o; heyecan dolu, meraklı,
araştırmacı, o soruşturmacı…
Adrenalin tutkusunu
sanıyorum en çok da bu
NTV’de altı yıl boyunca sahada
geçirdiğim yıllar çokça besledi.
Yine o dönem Bayrampaşa Cezaevi’nde,
F tipi cezaevlerini protestolar var.
Bayrampaşa Cezaevi’nde de protestolar var.
Gece yarısı bir telefon çaldı, sanırsınız
gizli göreve gidiyorum.
Parmak ucunda evden
çıktığımı hatırlıyorum.
Çatışmalar, patlamalar…
En son iki gün sonra tekrar eve döndüm.
Kısacası kitaplarda okuduğumuz,
filmlerde seyrettiğimiz
o hayatlara değmek dokunmak istedim.
Bu yüzden de hani mutfağın tam da
ortasında olmanız lazım.
Muhabirlik de bu işin mutfağıdır.
O yüzden o yemeğin mutlaka
biraz tuzunu ekmeniz lazım
ve hatta iki tas da kavurmanız lazım.
Çünkü yaşamadan anlatılmıyor,
anlatılsa da gerçekçi olmuyor.
O yüzden bugün genel
yayın yönetmeni olsam da
muhabir olarak kalmam, hep bu yüzden.
Çatışmalar, sorgular hepsi
bir yana dursun.
Sanıyorum duygusallık boyutumu
en çok da kol mesafesinde
gördüğüm iki yüzün üzerinde
cesette test ettim.
O dönem nişanlanıyorum.
Üzeyir Garih, bizim aile
dostumuz nişana katıldı.
Bir hafta sonra ben de haber
merkezinde oturuyorum,
polis telsizinden bir anons…
O dönem polis telsizi dinlerdik,
kodları hâlâ ezbere bilirim.
[POLİS TELSİZİ] “Üzeyir Garih,
Piyer Loti Mezarlığı’nda öldürüldü.”
Olabilir mi acaba dedim,
gerçek olabilir mi?
Koşa koşa gittim olay yerine.
Baktım, gerçekten o.
Kanlar içinde yatıyor.
Çok üzüldüm, saatlerce
ağladığımı hatırlıyorum.
Bütün bu olayı takip ettim.
Katil yakalandı, duruşmalar
başladı Fatih Adliyesi’nde.
Tek tek bütün o duruşmaların hepsine
katıldım ve adam dedi ki:
“Ben aslında sadece yaralamıştım.
Aşağıdan 'yardım, yardım' diye
bağırdığında tekrar yukarıya
çıktım ve öldürdüm” dedi.
Acaba dedim mümkün olabilir mi,
şüphecilik işte.
Gittim Piyer Loti Mezarlığı’na bir
kum saati koydum aşağıya,
bütün o merdivenleri indim çıktım.
Acaba bu kadar kısa sürede
öldürmüş olabilir mi diye.
Velhasıl bunun gibi çok olay yaşadım.
Kendi alanlarında lider olabilme
potansiyeline sahip kişilerin seçildiği,
Amerikan Dışişleri Bakanlığı’nın bir
programı vardı bir buçuk ay süren.
Ben de buna davetliydim.
Pentagon, Beyaz Saray gezilerinin
de içerildiği bir program.
O dönem Margaret Thatcher,
Süleyman Demirel…
Hepsi gençliklerinde katılmış.
O yılda programa davet
edilen tek Türk'tüm.
Nereden bilebilirdim ki yıllar
sonra meslek hayatımda
sırf bu programa katıldım diye
ajanlıkla suçlanacağımı…
On dokuz yılı aşkın meslek hayatımda
çok şey oldum aslında.
Ergenekoncu oldum, yandaş oldum.
Kendi ülkemin şu bayrağını takıyorum diye
-hani bilirsiniz Amerikalılar,
üzerlerine Amerikan bayrağından
tişört, üzerine şort giyerler-
ben kendi ülkemin ay yıldızlı
bayrağını taktım diye
bu ülkede ırkçı, faşist bile oldum.
Galiba kadın olunca hedef olmak
da bir o kadar kolay oluyor ve
doğrudur Türkiye’de kadın
olmak kolay değil.
Çünkü erkek egemen bir medyada mücadele
ediyoruz, çalışıyoruz hepimiz.
Mesela 1 Mayıs hiç unutmam, İşçi Bayramı.
Biz de o zaman hep beraber bütün
meslektaşlarla beraber çekime gittik.
O meşhur Perpa Köprüsü’nün üzerinde
bir hatıra fotoğrafı çekiyoruz;
resme baktım 22 yaşındaki bir ben
ve bir kadın meslektaşım
daha sadece iki kişiyiz.
Yine geçen hafta, sanıyorum
önceki haftaydı.
Çankaya Köşkü’ne, başbakan
televizyonların ve
gazetelerin genel yayın
yönetmenlerini çağırdı.
Hep birlikte gittik, üşenmedim saydım.
Masada 43 kişi, sadece ikisi
kadın, biri de ben.
Ne demek istediğimi aslında çok güzel
ortaya koyan bir tablo bu.
Çünkü sanıyorum bu erkek egemen
medyada o kadar çalıştık
çabaladık ki kadınlara pozitif
ayrımcılığı hep
kendi haber merkezimde
bilinçaltında uyguladım.
O yüzden bugün İstanbul Haber Müdürü’nden,
Ankara Haber Müdürü’ne;
Yurt Haber Editörü’nden,
Dış Haber Editörü’ne
tamamını kadınlara teslim ettim.
Erkekler yerer gibi olmasın ama kadınların
gözüne ve kalbine çok güveniyorum.
Yaptığımız iş de zaten kalp işi,
aşkla yapıyoruz
biz yaptığımız işi, tutkuyla yapıyoruz.
Aksi hâlde zaten yaptığınız
işten de hayır gelmiyor.
Mekanik değiliz tabii ki, elbette o
büyülü ekranın camın etrafında
en fazla da biz hırpalanıyoruz ve
insan çok travmatik olaylara
sahne olunca sanıyorum kırılma noktaları
da bir o kadar fazla oluyor.
Benimkilerden biri Mehmet.
Mehmet 7 yaşında, annesiyle
babası boşanmak üzereler,
velayet davası görülüyor.
Annesi Kur'an kursu hocası, babası İmam
ve babası bu kararın ardından farklı
bir şehirde yaşamaya karar veriyor.
Biz de bu duruşmayı takip ediyoruz ve
doğal olarak Mehmet’in de
yaşı küçük olduğundan velayetini
annesine veriyor mahkeme.
Sonrasında annesiyle kalmaya başlıyor.
Çocuk tabii, altına kaçırıyor.
Annesi döve döve komalık ediyor Mehmet’i.
Buz gibi bir betonun üzerine koyuyor,
sabaha kadar orada bekletiyor.
Korkusundan hastaneye bile kaldırmıyor.
Sonra anneanne geliyor sabaha karşı,
ne yaptın sen buna diyor.
İşte böyle böyle diyor, alıyorlar
hastaneye gidiyorlar.
Bir hafta boyunca ölümle yaşam
arasında mücadele ediyor,
hayatta kalmaya çalışıyor ama maalesef
yedi yaşında veda ediyor
bu hayata Mehmet.
Sonrasında Mehmet’in babası, çokça
etkileyen bir olaydır beni.
Çünkü aklımda hep şu görüntü kaldı:
O velayet davasında annesinin
kucağında Mehmet, ağlıyor
“Baba beni anneme bırakma,
beni çok dövüyor.” diye.
Annesi de cimcikliyor Mehmet’i,
daha fazla bağırmasın diye.
O haykırışları bir ay boyunca
gitmedi benim rüyalarımdan.
Sonrasında haber bitti,
duruşma süreci oldu.
Ben de haber sonrasında bir yorum yaptım.
İsyanım, öz annesi tarafından
öldürülüp üstelik
pişmanlık nedeniyle
cezasının indirilmesineydi.
Bir yorum yaptım.
Neyse haberler bitti, telefon çaldı
santralden arıyorlar.
Mehmet’in babası arıyor dediler,
o anda kafam karıştı.
“Kim? Mehmet? Tabii bağlayın” dedim.
“Merhabalar ben Mehmet’in babasıyım.
Ben küçücük yaşında çok
almaya uğraştım oğlumu.
Oğluma kavuşmaya çalıştım ama
mahkeme izin vermedi” dedi.
“Ben bu hayatta tutamadım Mehmet’i ama siz
sözlerinizle bir nebze olsun benim içimi
ferahlattınız. İyi ki varsınız!” dedi.
O günden beri her bayramda, her kandilde
arar beni Mehmet’in babası.
Mehmet’in babasını hiç tanımıyorum ama
işte bir yerde bir hayata
-Mehmet’in babasına- ve
belki de bu dünyadan göçüp giden o küçücük
Mehmet’in hayatına değip dokundum.
Tıpkı o Mehmet gibi diğer Mehmetler de hep
çok önemli oldu benim hayatımda.
Benim ailemde asker ya da polis yok ama
benim bu ülkenin askerine ve
polisine olan sevgim malumunuz.
Evet vatanseverim, Atatürkçüyüm ve
en büyük şansımın da bu topraklarda
doğup büyümek olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Ama buna karşılık bu ülkenin
askerinin ve polisinin
her zaman çok yalnız olduğunu hissettim.
Yeteri kadar önemsenmediğini hissettim
ve onların sesi olmaya karar verdim.
Belki onlar için önemlidir dedim ve özel
bir günde onların yanında olayım,
Yılbaşı gecesini onlarla
birlikte geçireyim dedim.
Nereye gideyim, nereye gideyim,
baktım en uzak yer neresi:
Sınırda Dağlıca var.
Hani birçoğunuz belki bilmez bile, 2015
yılında 16 şehit verdiğimiz yer.
Belki haritada bile yerini
zor bulursunuz ya da
çok çok haberlerde duymuş olabilirsiniz.
İki helikopter ve bir uçak…
Atladım gittim yanlarına.
Onlarla birlikte geçireyim diye...
Yılbaşı gecesi gidemedim,
güvenlik gerekçeleri
ve hava koşulları nedeni ile
iki hafta sonrasına gün verdiler ve
tam 24 saat çekim iznim var, gittim.
Tank atışları, top atışları
hepsini çektik.
2753 rakımlı Beybuta tepesine çıktık.
[HELİKOPTER SESİ]
Kuş uçmaz, kervan geçmez bir yer.
Hani burada görev yapabilmek için
gerçekten hayatta bir
amacınız olması lazım.
Bir vatan sevdası olması lazım,
bir bayrak sevgisi olması lazım.
Kocaman bir yüreğinizin olması lazım.
Çünkü bunun karşılığını
parayla ödeyemezsiniz.
Burada insanlar canını ortaya koyuyorlar.
Gittim, işte mağara gibi bir
yerde yatıp kalkıyorlar.
Zaten hava koşulları o kadar kötü ki,
-20 derece buz gibi soğuk
ve insan konuşmaya bile zorlanıyor.
2 metre kar…
Arada bir helikopter geliyor,
tepeden kumanyayı atıyor,
askerler yiyebildiği kadar yiyor.
Böyle bir yerde yatıp kalkıyorlar.
Sizin için, bizim için, hepimiz için…
Vatan için!
Sonrasında çekimler bitti,
Dağlıca’ya çıktık.
1500 askerle birlikte bir
gece geçiriyorum.
Çekimler bitti, oturduk sohbet
ettik derken yatacağız.
Hoş, uyumak ne mümkün.
Odaya geldim.
Tık tık kapı çaldı, 20 yaşlarında
gencecik bir astsubay:
“Nazlı Abla, bizimle beraber
biraz oturur musun?
Biz seni çok bekledik buraya
geleceksin diye.”
Oturmaz mıyım, tabii ki dedim.
Gittim yanlarına, onlar anlattı.
Kiminin terhisine şu kadar az kalmış,
kimi gün sayıyor.
Onlar anlatırken benim de
televizyona takıldı gözüm.
Çünkü bir müzik kanalı açık,
müzik kanalının altında
hani âşıkların birbirine notları,
mesajları geçer ya…
İşte her birinin bekleyeni var,
sevdalıları var.
O da yine sizin gibi, benim gibi.
Çekimler bitti ve oradan ayrıldım.
Bu arada buraya giderken…
Annem biraz pimpirikli, asla anneme
nereye gittiğimi söylemiyorum.
“Ankara’ya gidiyorum. Olağanüstü kurultay
var, kurultayda çekimler yapacağım” dedim.
Günlerden Pazar, artık 24 saati devirdik.
Van Filo’ya indik, son şeyler, birkaç
saat sonra uçak kalkacak.
Oturduk, bekliyoruz.
Bu esnada annem görüntülü
telefondan beni arıyor:
“Efendim” dedim.
“Ah küpelerimi yeni aldım,
güzel mi?” dedi.
Kaş göz yapıyorum şimdi, anlamadı ama
sesli görüntülü olunca
herkes bizi dinliyor.
“Ben sana bir yalan söyledim.
Ankara’da değilim.” dedim.
“Neredesin?” dedi.
“Dağlıca’dayım.” dedim.
“Orası neresi?” dedi.
İşte dedim böyle böyle Van, Hakkâri,
Yüksekova… İndim, bitti, geliyorum.
“Öldüreceğim seni buraya gelince, yeter
artık seninle mi uğraşacağım” falan…
Arkadan, “Ama inanmıyorum
kesin orada değilsindir.”
“Anne vallahi buradayım” dedim.
“Yok, yok. Hiç inanmıyorum”
Dedim şöyle bir göstereyim.
Yedi tane komutan oturmuş, annem
bir anda ayağa kalktı önünü ilikledi.
“Saygılar efendim, hepinize saygılar,
kızım size emanet.”
(Gülüşmeler)
Diyor ki “Gel, görüşeceğiz.”
Sonrasında yine Yüksekova’ya gittim,
orada da yine bombalar patlıyor.
Sokağa çıkma yasağı var. Çatışmalar…
Bari dedim söyleyeyim de
“Hayattayım” merak etmesin.
Birazdan çünkü haberler başlayacak,
görüntülerde anlayacak benim
orada olduğumu.
Önden aradım, nasıl bağırıyor bana,
“Hiç lafımı dinlemiyorsun.
Bıktım, yetti artık”
vesaire böyle bağırıyor bana.
Baktım çok bağırıyor, ben de
telefonunu kapadım.
Bir hafta boyunca küstü konuşmadı benimle.
“Küstüm seninle” dedi, başka
çare olmayınca.
Biz kanıksamayalım derken
şehit haberlerini,
alışmayalım derken en büyük
tehlike aslında onlarda.
Nusaybin’e gitmiştik ve Nusaybin’de sokağa
çıkma yasağı var, çatışmalar sürüyor.
İşte biz çekimleri yapacağız, onlar
operasyona çıkacaklar.
Hep beraber bir masada oturduk,
yine konuşuyoruz:
Nasıl yapmalıyız, bölgede ne
kadar gün kaldı,
ne kadarı temizlendi terör örgütünden
bunları anlatıyorlar.
Çayımızı içtik.
Biz çekime gittik, onlar operasyona gitti.
Aradan birkaç saat geçti,
tekrar geldik oturduk.
Ali’ye baktım, Ali yok yanımda.
“Ali nerede?” dedim.
“Ali şehit düştü.” dediler.
EYP (El yapımı patlayıcı) yüklü
binada, iki saat önce.
“Nasıl?” dedim. Ali şehit düştü.
Hani 60 saniyeyle giriyor
belki hayatlarımıza,
şehit haberleriyle giriyor.
Ağlayan bir anne, eş, yetim kalan, cami
avlusunda oynayan o çocuklar…
Sonrasında bitti diyoruz bizim için,
ama onlar için hayat hep yarım kalıyor.
Çünkü ateş düştüğü yeri yakıyor.
Onların hayatları artık hep yarım kalıyor.
Yine bir gün Dağlıca’dan dönüyoruz.
Askeri helikoptere bindik, arada bir, çok
nadiren kalkıyor zaten helikopterler.
Bir grup var asker, onlar da izine
çıkacaklar artık, çarşı izninlerine,
yüklenmişler balık istifi gibi hep
birlikte dolmuşuz helikopterin içerisine.
Giderken yanımda o kobra helikopterlerinin
pilotlarından ikisi oturuyor.
Dedi ki resmimizi çeker misiniz ama siz
bir selfie (özçekim) yapın bizimle…
Tabii ki dedim, birlikte
böyle resim çektik.
Aradan 22 gün geçti, Burak…
Şehit haberi geldi.
Acıları hep biriktirdik ve
hep bir bedel ödüyor insan.
Ben de başta IŞİD, PKK olmak üzere
onlarca davadan yargılandım.
Hâlâ yargılanıyorum.
Ölüm tehditleri, mecliste soruşturmalar,
hakaretler, tehditler…
Mesela emniyet bir canlı bomba
listesi dağıtmıştı,
birkaç kişinin canlı bomba
olması nedeniyle.
Bunu haberleştirir misiniz dediler,
biz de haberleştirdik.
İki gün sonra aşağıdan aradılar
beni, güvenlikten.
“Tebligat geldi” dediler.
Dedim herhâlde yine dava açıldı.
Gittim baktım, o haberini
yaptığımız kızlardan biri
“Sen nasıl bana canlı bomba dersin
ben üniversite öğrencisiyim,
yok öyle bir şey” dedi.
Ben tabii adliyeyelere gittim.
İfadeler veriyorum, gittim geldim.
Aradan bir vakit geçti, iki sene geçti.
İstanbul’da Vatan Emniyet Müdürlüğü
önünde bir çatışma…
Bir polis şehit, iki tane de
kız yatıyor yerde.
Üstlerinde bombalar bağlı,
ellerinde kalaşnikof.
Ölmüş teröristler.
O kızlardan biriydi işte bana
iki yıl önce dava açan.
Otomatik beraat ettim.
Getirisi mi daha fazla oldu, götürüsü mü?
Hiçbir zaman bilemedim ama
fark yaratmak istedim ve
bu kurulu düzende uyuyanları biraz
da olsun uyandırmak istedim aslında.
Ve ne yaptıysam aşkla, tutkuyla yaptım.
Davalar, soruşturmalar…
Hâliyle her anne gibi benim annem de
“Yeter artık yoruldun bırak şu işi.
Dünyayı sen mi kurtaracaksın?” diyor.
Yok, dünyayı kurtarmaya benim
gücüm yetmez ama
oturduğum koltukta belki biraz olsun
bir şeyleri değiştirmeye
gücüm yeter diye düşündüm.
Ve ben herkes kendi kapısının
önünü süpürürse farklı bir
Türkiye olacağına inandım her zaman.
Kızıma bırakacak koca koca binalarım,
arazilerim yok belki
ama bir şeyleri değiştirmek adına
çabalamış bir annesi olacak.
Yol bir yerde bitiyor,
bitecek elbette hepimiz için.
Önemli olan kaç kişinin
hayatına dokunduğumuz ve
kaç kişi için fark yaratabilmiş
olacağımız olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Hepinize teşekkürler!
(Alkış)